how you doing 5 six
[Laughter]
78 that would have been a good place for
Amber to drop right there yeah yeah it
would damn mhm whoa do we get monetized
for that or demonetized for that just
that whoa yeah maybe for being too sick
whoa Amber is your color en too long too
long too long too long cuz we sound too
similar to him so the waveforms are
probably very similar yeah we our voices
are pretty damn good yeah if you're
listening on audio we have new
carpet and if you're watching on video
you can see it yeah looks pretty damn
good it looks really good I like this
blue no it is it's um I was saying this
last week it's like it makes it like
moodier in here yeah it's like a little
bit more like emotional but also like
ties everything together yeah it's nice
you know what it also reminds me of the
casino
floor of oh it's it's the new casino
what is that new
one shoot can you look up New Vegas
casinos
it really is the same it's a similar
tone do you think there's do you think
there's SL machines at in the
sphere no it's like the only thing that
can make that cooler n it's just a vibe
in there yeah you saw the ad rates for
that thing oh yeah yeah the outside of
it yeah 400k for uh an hour or something
no no no for a day day a day an hour
dude I don't know it could be an hour
would be
[__] what what are the
damn that was so Canadian right there
we'll be
[__] yeah we'd be [__] buddy it' be
[__] buddy E Buddy that'd be [__] e
what can we just get a list of the new
Las Vegas casinos it's just on the tip
of my tongue it's on the tip of my
tongue you used to have yeah Resorts
World the
most what does he say yeah you used to
have the most geographic tongue what is
that from this dude infra Bren on on Tik
Tok What okay he is like one of the
original he's been I've talked about him
before he he's been on YouTube for like
11 years okay doing awkward ass pranks
okay he has one where he goes in the
library and he just keeps playing porn
repeatedly it's like he's like sorry
sorry I don't know how to stop it really
and then he'll stop he's like so sorry
about
that so oh [__] what was the one that we
talked about recently that he did uh the
one where I recognize his name yeah he
went up to the the kid and he's like I'm
calling the cops on you yeah yeah so
good yeah so the one I love is he goes
up to this old guy this older guy and he
goes you remember me it's Bren yeah we
used to play in your
treehouse you had the most geographic
tongue what the [__] does it even mean
and we used to run egg dye down your
tongue to see which color would get to
the end the guy's just staring at him
like what's the punch line on that one
and he's like and then then yeah then he
goes like he's like and you know you
remember what he used to say it's on the
tip of my tongue remember you used to
say it's something to that tune dude
it's so good way too specific and weird
yeah like that's why that works cuz the
person's like okay this must be real
yeah he got this dude we must have
actually done this yeah he got this dude
in Walmart to drink a beer with him in
the bed of his truck what he's like come
on out
come on just have a Bruce like I'm
paraphrasing you know I'm not giving the
exact dialogue but he gets this [__]
random guy to just post up with him in
his truck bed at Walmart and they just
drink a beer he just gets him to hang
it's so
wild it's so wild man was it B bony n
that he like I don't know how long B
Bon's doing it been doing it but he's
definitely bren's like a veteran he's
veteran straight
up Bren is did you see the [__] kid
that got shot yeah you watch that video
yeah I mean it was a little bit like
yeah you know well the dude what like
what oh you didn't see it some so
basically like some like budding
prankster YouTubers were [__] with
this guy in a mall this random guy and
they were going up and like didn't even
really seem like a prank I don't even
know what it was they were like playing
some super loud sound and being like
what do you think what do you think like
really getting in his face and like
being weird about it they weren't like
being pranky about it it was pretty like
threatening I would say and then the guy
just pulls out a gun and shoots the kid
but like in the knee or
something stomach yeah he lived though
yeah blammed
him so yeah play
it probably going to have to mute this
he quit thinking about my twinkle what's
that he quit thinking about my twinkle
no about my face
stop
stop yeah little 22 that [__] have set
you right yeah but yeah he was being it
was like it felt like what's going on
yeah this got posted on Twitter and
everyone was like yeah [__] that kid
got taught a lesson basically and then
it went to court and basically he just
he basically didn't get convicted of any
like serious gun charge it was like a
light like the lightest charge you can
get for shooting in a mall basically but
not it was like basically ruled of
self-defense I think he's still facing
like two to 10 years though for yeah
yeah yeah so it's still a heavy ass it's
still at heast going to jail for that
for sure which I mean yeah don't pull
out a gun in them all but at the same
time it's like maybe what this happen
Florida uh some I don't know Virginia I
don't know man I don't know that case
might hit that [__] judge and be like
let me get this
rat so he come up to
you and he in your face with a
phone and you shot him in his stomach
with a
22 10 days community service yeah the
worst part about it is that the kid like
I I watched some like News Channel like
reporting on it and they were like and
uh
like you know what is his name
cole Cole says he plans to continue his
prank youtubing after this like no dude
PA's the
shooter tan what's the guy Tanner of
course yeah
Tanner I mean I my name is Cody I
shouldn't talk but Tanner is kind of a
perfect name for a YouTube prankster
yeah you know and Tanner says he's going
to continue doing his YouTube prank
videos after this and like no you got
shot in the stomach isn't that like a
sign like okay I'm not the best at this
yeah I don't have the Finesse you know
mhm yeah like you can see it from that
video the dude is just he's like you
don't have it dude yeah you don't have
it you're scary you're scaring that man
and you got shot in the stomach the
pranking Casting
Couch you get shot and that's how you
know you failed yeah all right we're
going to put you in a room there yeah
you're going to go prank this guy yeah
and they have a loaded firearm and
that's how we're going to know if you're
if you're the Next Generation nek see
and if if you were INF for Brin yeah 10
minutes later you'd be drinking a beer
with that guy yeah you'd have that guy
outside yeah you'd have the gun you the
gun you'd have the gun broken down in
pieces yeah yeah remember you the guy
would be the guy would be eating it yeah
yeah yeah yeah you used to just drink
that little gunpowder shake you remember
that you remember that you used to be so
good at eating ammo don't you remember
like just swallowing bullets how did you
do
that it's going to be weird when that
kid Tanner has to like pivot to like
Christian content in two years what do
you mean well when the prank stuff
doesn't work out yeah but he wants views
yeah yeah yeah he'll become like a
Christian YouTuber yeah gay people are
wrong be like aren't you the guy that
got shot in the in the stomach yeah
that's the thing he's always going to be
that dude who got shot yeah dude got
shot in the stomach yeah he's lucky it
wasn't more cuz uh I wonder what the
caliber was cuz 22 you're not you're
from what I understand you're not
allowed to shoot people with 22s because
they cause way more damage like they
just get stuck in there and as you move
around it just like continues to rip and
I'm going take a bite of
my that giving you an appetite
mhm